el presidente francisco sagasti anunció
que perú comprará scinopharm de china 38
millones de dosis de su vacuna contra el
cob y 19 y también adquirirá 14 millones
de dosis del medicamento producido por
oxford astrazéneca de inglaterra los
ensayos clínicos de fase 3 realizados en
el perú no sólo nos han colocado en una
mejor posición para acceder a las
vacunas de scinopharm sino que también
nos han servido para comprobar su
efectividad en la población nacional de
esta manera esperamos tener vacunados
entre 14 y 15 millones de peruanos antes
de que arrecie la temporada de invierno
en nuestro país las vacunas han sido
cuestionadas y rechazadas por algunos
congresistas quienes interpondrán una
demanda de inconstitucionalidad contra
la ley que sustenta la compra en mi
persona va a plantear no este la demanda
de inconstitucionalidad porque esta
vacuna es una vacuna insegura no ha
pasado la fase 3 de experimentación de
investigación ya no tiene los estudios
concluidos
es una vacuna que va a poner en riesgo
la salud de la población pero sufre la
segunda ola de la pandemia del cobi 19
con más de un millón de contagiados y
alrededor de 40.000 muertos por
coronavirus sin embargo un 48% de
peruanos se niega a recibir la vacuna no
me pienso vacunar porque no estoy
preparada en primer lugar y pienso que
este es como un conejillo de indias
tengo dudas acerca de la eficacia de la
vacuna hay mucho
posibles vacunas pero no se han dado los
resultados exactos otros peruanos se
muestran favorables como en otros países
se pide al gobierno mayor información y
campañas educativas sobre la necesidad
de que la vacunación sea masiva
quiero informarme más sobre la seguridad
y la garantía de esa vacuna para vacunar
yo voy dispuesto a vacunar porque soy
una persona ya que tercero hay gente que
no está bien informado parece que no
quieren
pero no debemos vacunar los todos tienen
vacunarse todos el primer lote de
vacunas casino farm envía perú es de un
millón de dosis servirá para inmunizar
al personal sanitario miembros de la
policía y las fuerzas armadas